This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here at 99PI, we do stories about all kinds of things. Stories about architecture, about transit, about history, even the occasional sports story. But one kind of story that always elicits a huge response from a very vocal constituency are stories about type. You guys love stories about fonts and typefaces. So a couple months ago, I was having dinner with Helen Zaltzman and her husband and collaborator Martin Austwick, and she told me about a story they developed for a live stage show about an epic feud over a typeface of all things.
这里是“隐藏的99%”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在99PI，我们制作关于各种事物的节目。关于建筑的、交通的、历史的，甚至偶尔有体育故事。但有一种故事总能引起一个非常直言不讳的群体的热烈反响，那就是关于字体字型的故事。你们大家都很喜欢关于字体和字型的故事。所以在几个月前，我和海伦·扎尔茨曼以及她的丈夫兼合作者马丁·奥斯特维克共进晚餐，她向我讲述了他们为一个现场舞台演出开发的故事，讲的是关于一个字型的史诗级不和，简直匪夷所思。
And I knew I had to get that story on the show. We're talking about two people who set up an artisanal printing press, which was kind of unusual at the time. They were very groundbreaking in their way. And it was also not really something. that people did if they didn't already have money. You might recognize Helen's voice if you, like me, are a listener to the illusionist or answer me this, but this piece is an adaptation of an illusionist live show that Helen and Martin did called Souvenirs. Here it is.
我知道我必须把这个故事搬上节目。我们说的是两个人创办了一个手工作坊式的印刷厂，这在当时可以说是相当罕见的。他们在自己的路上非常具有开拓性。而且，如果他们本来就没钱的话，这也不是人们会去做的事情。如果你和我一样是《幻术师》或《回答我这个》的听众，你可能会认出海伦的声音，但这个片段是海伦和马丁做过的一个名为《纪念品》的《幻术师》现场演出的改编。节目开始了。
This is the story of the friendship of Thomas Cobden-Sanderson and Emery Walker, and of the implosion of that friendship. We know the impact of what they said to each other, but we don't know their exact words, so Thomas will be performed by the Glock Spiel and Emery by violin. Two friends brought together and driven apart by type. Yes, type as in printed lettering. I'm the narrator Helen Zaltzman and this is our orchestra and chorus, Martin Austwick. Type means the design, the way that letters look and the little bits of metal that print words in a book We find Thomas and Emory in London, in the District of Hammersmith,
这是关于托马斯·科布登-桑德森与埃默里·沃克之间的友谊，以及这段友谊的崩溃的故事。我们知道他们对彼此说的话所产生的影响，但我们不知道他们的确切言辞，所以托马斯将由乐音琴演奏，埃默里由小提琴演奏。两个因字体而聚到一起又因字体而分道扬镳的朋友。是的，字体就像印刷文字一样。我是旁白海伦·扎尔茨曼，这是我们的管弦乐队和合唱团，马丁·奥斯特维克。字体意味着设计、字母的外观以及在书中打印文字的那些小块金属。我们在伦敦汉默史密斯区找到了托马斯和埃默里，
where their houses were and their workplaces. We don't know exactly how they first met in the late 1880s, perhaps in your favourite local pub, the Doves. In a tightly packed bar, you could have bumped into each other. That's all right. Maybe one of you bought the other a drink. You shared a joke Did all the getting to know you, chat?
他们的房子和工作场所就在那里。我们不知道他们在19世纪80年代末是如何初次相遇的，也许是在你最喜欢的当地酒吧“鸽子”里。在一个挤满人的酒吧里，你们可能会撞到对方。没关系。也许你们中的一个人给另一个人买了一杯饮料。你们分享了一个笑话，做了所有互相了解的闲聊？
Where did you grow up? Where'd you get a good price on moustache wax these days? Who's your favourite spice girl? The same one. However it happened, sometime, somewhere your friendship was born. Friendship never ends. The spice girls taught us so
你在哪里长大的？你最近在哪里能买到价格实惠的胡须蜡？你最喜欢的辣妹组合成员是谁？同一个人。不管它是怎么发生的，在某个时间，某个地方，你们的友谊诞生了。友谊永不落幕。辣妹组合就是这么教我们的。
We'll be each other's right or die until it's time to go. You two ran in the same circles because you shared two major interests, socialist politics and printing. A friend describes you Thomas as a seeker all his life. You dealt with depression and often life was hard for you because you really felt things so keenly. You had been a lawyer, but you became a bookbinder after your wife, Annie, complained that your...
我们将成为彼此生死与共的伙伴，直到离别时刻的到来。你们两个在同一个圈子里活动，因为你们有两个共同的主要兴趣：社会主义政治和印刷。一个朋友这样形容你，托马斯，你一生都在寻求。你一直在与抑郁症作斗争，生活对你来说常常很艰难，因为你对事物的感受实在是太敏锐了。你曾是一名律师，但在你的妻子安妮抱怨你的...
interests were too abstract. You took to bookbinding very quickly, Thomas, and were brilliant at it, the best in the biz. In 1893, you set up your own book bindery, the Doves Bindery, named after your favourite pub, which was two doors along from the bindery. Emory, you had had a difficult childhood. You grew up in poverty, and you'd had to leave school, age 13, after your father was blinded by an accident at work, so you needed to earn money for the family. You didn't have much, but you did have some books and you loved them. This led you to a career in typography, and in 1886, Emery,
兴趣太抽象之后，你成为了一名书籍装订工。托马斯，你很快就学会了书籍装订，并且精通此道，是业内最棒的。1893年，你建立了自己的书籍装订厂——“鸽子装订厂”，以你最喜欢的酒吧命名，该酒吧距离装订厂只有两道门远。埃默里，你有着一个艰难的童年。你在贫困中长大，由于父亲在工作事故中失明，你13岁就不得不辍学，所以你需要为家庭赚钱。你没有多少东西，但你确实有一些书，而且你热爱它们。这引导你走上了排版印刷的职业道路，并在1886年，埃默里，
you also founded a photo-engraving company capable of unprecedentedly good reproductions of photographs and illustrations, magical for the time, the cuttingest of cutting edges. Both of you, Emery and Thomas, were big deals in the art and craft of making books, and once you found each other,
你还创立了一家照相制版公司，能够对照片和插图进行前所未有地出色的复制，这在当时堪称神奇，处于最尖端的尖端。你们两个，埃默里和托马斯，在制作书籍的艺术和工艺方面都是大人物，一旦你们找到了彼此，
you encouraged each other, in the best friendships you do amplify one another. Shine a light in the mirror, double the light. Thomas once sent Emery a note written in a discarded bookbinding. It said, To a Perfect Friend, an Imperfect Souverneur. These words transform a piece of rubbish into an object with value. Souverneur is French for memory, and therefore all souvenirs must be imperfect. souvenir
你们就相互鼓励，在最好的友谊中，你们确实会放大彼此。在镜子里照亮，让光芒加倍。托马斯曾给埃默里发过一张便条，写在一张废弃的装订纸上。上面写着：“致完美的朋友，不完美的纪念品”。这些话将一件垃圾变成了一件有价值的物品。Souverneur是法语中的记忆，因此所有的纪念品都必须是不完美的。纪念品
We don't need reminders Because you're always near Really near Because Emory lived at number three Hammersmith Terrace And in 1897 Thomas and his family moved into number seven Down the Street
我们不需要提醒 因为你总是近在咫尺 真的近在咫尺 因为埃默里住在汉默史密斯露台3号 并且在1897年 托马斯和他的家人搬到了街同侧的7号
And half a mile east along the River Thames Emory rented his business premises from Thomas Who worked at his bindery next door So your work and domestic lives were very close Even that wasn't close enough, you went on family holidays together at neighbouring cottages. And even that wasn't close enough after at least a decade of friendship. In 1890, you decided to take your relationship to the next level. You set up a printing press together.
沿着泰晤士河向东半英里 埃默里从托马斯那里租下了他的营业场所 托马斯就在隔壁的装订厂工作 所以你们的工作和家庭生活非常贴近 即使那样还不够亲密，你们还一起去邻近的度假屋进行家庭度假。即使在至少十年的友谊之后，那也还不够亲密。1890年，你们决定将关系提升到一个新的水平。你们一起创办了一家印刷厂。
The Doves Press. Friendship never ends. Spice girls told us so. We'll be each other's right or die Until it's time to go We can carve them in stone We can cast them in steel What lasts longer than the words
鸽子印刷厂。友谊永不落幕。辣妹组合就是这么告诉我们的。我们将成为彼此生死与共的伙伴，直到离别时刻的到来。我们可以将它们刻在石头上，我们可以将它们铸造在钢铁中。比言语更持久的是
Is the way they make you feel The Doves Press was born Thomas you had all this passion for type design What you called The Book Beautiful But you didn't really know anything about printing. And for that, you needed Emery, who knew all about how to set up and run a printing press. A few years earlier, Emery, you'd set up a press with none other than William Morris, and you helped him design his own typefaces. William Morris asked you to be his business partner,
是它们带给你的感受。鸽子印刷厂诞生了，托马斯，你对字体设计有着满腔的热情，你称之为“美丽之书”。但你对印刷其实一无所知。为此，你需要埃默里，他精通如何建立和运营一家印刷厂。几年前，埃默里，你曾与威廉·莫里斯共同创办了一家印刷厂，并且你帮他设计了他自己的字体。威廉·莫里斯邀请你做他的商业合伙人，
and you actually turned him down because you thought he would have been too controlling. But when Thomas asked you to be his partner, you said yes. Emory, you couldn't afford to contribute financially to the business. And Thomas, you didn't have any money of your own, but your wife Annie was from a wealthy family, so she lent you money to start up the business, £1,600, equivalent in today's money to about £250,000. I know, Thomas, you were so excited. You wrote a letter to your teenage son, Dickie, about how you'd cleared out the attic at your bindery to fill with print equipment, and you couldn't wait to sit on a high stool next to your great friend, Emery, both printing your hearts out. Were you excited too, Emery? Ah, nobody had asked you if you wanted to sit on a
而你其实拒绝了他，因为你认为他掌控欲太强了。但当托马斯邀请你做他的合伙人时，你答应了。埃默里，你无力在财务上为这个生意做贡献。而托马斯，你自己没有任何钱，但你的妻子安妮来自一个富裕的家庭，所以她借给你钱来创业，1600英镑，相当于今天的金钱大约25万英镑。我知道，托马斯，你太兴奋了。你给十几岁的儿子迪基写了一封信，讲述了你如何清理装订厂的阁楼来摆放印刷设备，你迫不及待地想坐在伟大朋友埃默里身旁的高脚凳上，两人都尽情地印刷。埃默里，你也感到兴奋吗？啊，没有人问过你想不想坐在
high stool printing. It's okay though. The two of you had the jewel and the Doves Presses Crown, your own in-house typeface, Doves type. Doves type was based on a typeface designed by French printer Nicholas Jensen in Venice in the late 1400s, but Thomas and Emery wanted their type to look to the future, not to the past. The ornate printing styles of the time Thomas found unreadable. Doves' press books were to be beautiful in themselves, without illustrations, without ornamentation.
高脚凳上印刷。不过没关系。你们两个拥有鸽子印刷厂王冠上的明珠——你们自己的内部字体，鸽子体。鸽子体是以1400年代末威尼斯法国印刷商尼古拉·詹森设计的字体为基础的，但托马斯和埃默里希望他们的字体面向未来，而不是过去。托马斯发现当时的华丽印刷风格无法阅读。鸽子印刷厂的书籍本身就应该是美丽的，没有插图，没有装饰。
The letters should not be more beautiful than the literature they were forming. We can carve them in stone, we can cast them in steel. What lasts longer than the words is the way they make you feel. The dove's type was lauded at the time as... Trimmed to a slim grace which suggests a racehorse at the top of its training
字母不应比它们所构成的文学作品更美丽。我们可以将它们刻在石头上，我们可以将它们铸造在钢铁中。比言语更持久的是它们带给你的感受。鸽子体在当时被称赞为……修剪成苗条的优雅，让人联想起处于训练巅峰状态的赛马，
with no ounce of superfluous flesh but full of spring and life. Wow, people were really horny for type back then. And the Doves Press began printing books that were received as aesthetically revelatory with their undecorated white margins and text in plain black 16-point dove's type enlivened with graceful but unostentatious red letters, hand-drawn by the calligrapher Edward Johnston, who went on later to design the iconic typeface of the London transport system. The Doves Press was a huge influence on typography and book design.
身上没有一盎司多余的肉，却充满弹性和生命力。哇，那时候的人对字体真是太狂热了。鸽子印刷厂开始印刷那些被认为在美学上具有启发性的书籍，它们有着未加装饰的白色页边距，正文采用朴素的黑色的16磅鸽子体，并点缀着用书法家爱德华·约翰斯顿手绘的优雅而不张扬的红色字母，他后来为伦敦交通系统设计了标志性的字体。鸽子印刷厂对排版和书籍设计产生了巨大的影响。
When the Doves Press printed Bibles, critics said, Oh, even if you've already got a Bible, you have to try these Doves Press Bibles. I don't know, man, they're just so much more biblie than the other Bibles. These Doves Press Bibles now sell for £45,000. Thomas and Emery brought complementary skills to the Doves Press. Thomas perfectionism, Emery pragmatism. Thomas is all about the art of printing, and Emery is all about the business. So it should have been a great success.
当鸽子印刷厂印刷《圣经》时，评论家们说，哦，即使你已经有了一本《圣经》，你也必须试试这些鸽子印刷厂的《圣经》。我不知道，伙计，它们比其他《圣经》要好得多。这些鸽子印刷厂的《圣经》现在售价45,000英镑。托马斯和埃默里为鸽子印刷厂带来了互补的技能。托马斯的完美主义，埃默里的实用主义。托马斯专注于印刷艺术，而埃默里则专注于商业。所以这本该是一个巨大的成功。
But Thomas is all about the art of printing, and Emery is all about the business. Things started to go sour almost immediately. Who knows exactly what they said? Furious rouse or giving each other the cold shoulder? Thomas and Emery, you were not on the same page. All right, Thomas, yes, you felt you were doing all the work of the printing and the proofreading, and Emery was hardly ever there, and didn't respond to your lengthy arguments about the best, and in your opinion only way to design the word of.
但托马斯专注于印刷艺术，而埃默里则专注于商业。事情几乎立刻就开始变坏了。谁知道他们究竟说了什么？是激烈的争吵还是冷落彼此？托马斯和埃默里，你们不在同一个频道上。好吧，托马斯，是的，你觉得你包办了所有的印刷和校对工作，而埃默里几乎从不在场，并且对你关于设计文字的最佳方式的长篇大论置之不理，在你看来那是唯一的方式。
You were a perfect friend But now I despair Of still looks all wrong to me And you still don't care Oh yeah, Emery you did care But you had a whole other business to run Because you had to earn money to live And you needed to get things done quickly
你曾是完美的朋友 但现在我感到绝望 它在我看来仍然完全错误 而你依然漠不关心 哦，是的，埃默里，你确实在乎 但你还有另一个生意要经营 因为你必须赚钱谋生 并且你需要把事情快点办完
That Thomas liked to spend weeks or months mulling over You were so busy, you'd never stop to eat lunch you'd keep going until dinner, which was wine and one large onion. Just a whole onion? Raw? Eating like an apple? Also, you were there at the printing press when you could be, and when you did express your opinions about what was being printed,
而托马斯喜欢花几周或几个月的时间来仔细琢磨。你太忙了，从来不停下来吃午饭，你会一直忙到晚饭，晚饭就是酒和一个大洋葱。就只有一个洋葱？生的？像吃苹果一样吃？此外，只要有可能，你就会去印刷厂，当你确实对正在印刷的东西发表意见时，
Thomas would respond somewhere between unreceptive and furious. Thomas says, Emory has onion breath. But here was the real point of contention. Emory, you always referred to Doves as our press, whereas Thomas, you would say my press. Ouch! It was only two years between the release of the Spice Girl's first single,
托马斯的反应介于难以接受和暴怒之间。托马斯说，埃默里有洋葱味。但真正的争论点在这里。埃默里，你总是把鸽子印刷厂称为“我们的印刷厂”，而托马斯，你会说“我的印刷厂”。哎哟！从辣妹组合的第一支单曲发行，
Wannaby and Jerry leaving the band. Did that feel like longer to you? It did to me, but in reality it was just under two years. And that was about the amount of time that the Doves press had been going, before Thomas wanted to break up with Emery or Emery wanted to break up with Thomas. Have any of you experienced friendship breakups in adulthood? Mine have felt more acutely painful than romantic breakups,
《Wannabe》到杰瑞退队，仅仅过去了两年。你觉得这时间过得更久吗？对我来说是这样的，但实际上不到两年。而这也就是鸽子印刷厂开办的时间，在那之后，托马斯就想和埃默里分道扬镳，或者埃默里想和托马斯分道扬镳。你们有谁在成年后经历过友谊的破裂吗？我的经历让我觉得比浪漫关系的破裂还要痛苦得多，
and there aren't even songs to soundtrack the predicament. Friendship never ends. Why would the spice girls lie? We thought we'd be each other's pal Until one of us die. I don't know if there is such a thing as a clean break, but there is such a thing as a quick break, and this was not it. The Doves Press officially opened in 1900.
甚至连作为这种困境背景音乐的歌曲都没有。友谊永不落幕。为什么辣妹组合会说谎？我们以为我们会是彼此的伙伴 直到我们中的一个人死去。我不知道是否存在彻底的决裂，但确实存在迅速的决裂，而这并不是那样。鸽子印刷厂于1900年正式开业。
By 1902, Thomas and Emory's friendship was in ruins, but the working partnership didn't officially end for another seven years. Seven years is the length of time between the Spice Girls going on indefinite hiatus and reforming for a reunion tour, including Jerry. That's how long it took these two just to break up. And during that time, even though you had fallen out and were fighting a lot, you still went on holidays to the cottages that were next door to each other. Why? Why didn't you go somewhere else?
到1902年，托马斯和埃默里的友谊已经毁于一旦，但工作伙伴关系在之后的七年里才正式结束。七年是辣妹组合进入无限期中断到重组巡回演出（包括杰瑞）之间的时间长度。这两个人仅仅是分个手就花了这么长时间。在那期间，尽管你们已经闹翻并且经常争吵，你们还是去了彼此隔壁的度假屋度假。为什么？你们为什么不去别的地方？
Of course, you both didn't see why you should be the one to not go. Friendship never ends, except for when it does. It hurts worse than gold stones But at least we've still got doves Yeah, at least we've still got doves right fellas One of the reasons Thomas and Emery's breakup was so protracted Was because of a battle over who would get custody of the doves type Which legally belonged to both of them
当然，你们两个都不明白为什么自己应该成为那个不去的人。友谊永不落幕，除非它确实结束了。它比胆结石还要痛 但至少我们还有鸽子 是的，至少我们还有鸽子对吧，伙计们 托马斯和埃默里分手的过程之所以如此漫长，原因之一是因为争夺鸽子体所有权的战斗，该字体在法律上属于他们俩
But Thomas wanted to keep doves for his sole use He didn't want Emery or anyone else to print anything in doves that he didn't control. And remember, at this time, type was a physical object, or rather thousands of physical objects, so you couldn't just make infinite digital copies. And if you didn't have the type, then you didn't have the type.
但托马斯想把鸽子体留作自己独家使用。他不想让埃默里或其他任何人印刷任何他无法控制的鸽子体内容。请记住，在那个时代，字体是一个实体对象，或者更确切地说是数千个实体对象，所以你不能只制作无限的数字副本。如果你没有这种字模，那么你就没有这种字模。
So Thomas offered Emery a small amount of money to relinquish his claim on dubs. Emery didn't accept. They battled back and forth, back and forth for years. Meanwhile, the Dutch Doves Press was financially failing. It was successful in making and selling its beautiful hand-printed books, but hand-printing is not where the big money is, or where the small money is. Private printing presses were a rich man's game, and neither Thomas nor Emery was a rich man.
所以托马斯向埃默里提供了一小笔钱，让他放弃对鸽子字体的权利要求。埃默里没有接受。他们来来回回地争斗，年复一年。与此同时，荷兰鸽子印刷厂在财务上正在走向失败。它在制作和销售精美的手工印刷书籍方面是成功的，但手工印刷并不是能赚大钱或小钱的地方。私人印刷厂是有钱人的游戏，而托马斯和埃默里都不是有钱人。
Emery wanted to cut the losses and shut down the Doves' press. Thomas disagreed, and banned Emery from the premises. To get some cash to keep the press going, Thomas and his wife Annie rented out their home, Annie went to stay with her sister, and Thomas moved into the attic of the Doves Press and Bindery, directly above where his ex-business partner Emery was still working at his photo-engraving business in the space he rented from Thomas. Things started to get so ugly between Thomas and Emery, court proceedings began. But somehow, late in 1908, they did at last reach a compromise. Thomas, who was a decade older than Emory, would continue to use the Doves type for the rest of his life. And upon his death, it would become Emery's.
埃默里想要及时止损并关闭鸽子印刷厂。托马斯不同意，并禁止埃默里进入该场所。为了获得一些现金来维持印刷厂的运转，托马斯和他的妻子安妮把他们的家租了出去，安妮去和她的姐姐住在一起，而托马斯搬到了鸽子印刷厂和装订厂的阁楼里，就在他的前商业伙伴埃默里仍在从托马斯那里租来的空间里从事他的照相制版业务的楼上方。托马斯和埃默里之间的关系开始变得如此糟糕，以至于诉讼程序开始了。但不知何故，在1908年底，他们终于达成了妥协。比埃默里大十岁的托马斯将在他的余生中继续使用鸽子字体。在他去世后，它将归埃默里所有。
It's a kind of a morbid deal, but it was a deal. In 1909, after seven years of wrangling, the Dobs Press Partnership was at last declared officially over. And here is where our story turns to, If I can't have you, no one will, but make it type. When our friendship ends, because the spice goes light, I'll need you to know I hate you Even after I've died
这是一种有些病态的交易，但这确实是一笔交易。1909年，经过七年的争吵，鸽子印刷厂合伙关系终于被宣布正式结束。这就是我们的故事转向的地方：“如果我得不到你，谁也别想得到，但把它做成字模。”当我们的友谊结束时，因为辣妹组合的离去，我需要你知道我恨你，甚至在我死后
Because what did you do, Thomas? What did you do? You threw the dove's type Into the river Throwing something away into a body of water Sounds spontaneous, doesn't it? Like in a film someone rips up a photo of their ex and flushes it down the toilet
因为你做了什么，托马斯？你做了什么？你把鸽子字体扔进了河里。把某样东西扔进水体听起来很冲动，对吧？就像在电影里，有人撕毁了他们前任的照片并把它冲进马桶一样
Or they throw their engagement ring into a lake Whereas throwing away a whole tight face was a lot more time and effort. For once Thomas, you chose action over abstraction. You planned this for how long? Seven years. Thomas, you were really excited about this and you were really excited about eventually getting found out. But you waited, you waited long enough to write a 116 page apologia about why you did it. Let's not forget the word apolloja does not mean an apology. It's a defense argument. You were going to publish it too, weren't you, Thomas, in 1913, but you realised it might be incriminating. So, you waited. You waited until you wanted to close down the Doves
或者他们把订婚戒指扔进湖里，而扔掉一整副铅字需要更多的时间和精力。托马斯，破天荒地，你选择了行动而非抽象。你策划了多久？七年。托马斯，你对此感到非常兴奋，你也为最终被人发现感到非常兴奋。但你等了，你等了足够长的时间，写了一篇116页的辩护信，解释你为什么这么做。别忘了，apologia这个词并不意味着道歉。它是一个辩护论点。你本来也要发表它，不是吗，托马斯，在1913年，但你意识到这可能会泄露罪证。所以，你等了。你等到了你想关闭Doves
press, and until you were printing the last ever Doves book. And when you were ready, which was one night in August 1916, you waited till dusk. Then you walked the half-mile from home to Hammersmith Bridge that spans the River Thames. You crossed towards the south side where the water was deepest, and you threw the type into the river. And this wasn't just a one-night thing, because Thomas, how much type can you carry in one go? 10 or 15 pounds? And how much type was there altogether? At least 2,600 pounds. So, to get rid of 2,600 pounds of metal type, a maximum of 15 pounds at a time, means you went to the bridge how many times?
印刷所，直到你正在印刷最后一本Doves的书。当你准备好的时候，那是在1916年8的一个夜晚，你等到了黄昏。然后你步行了半英里，从家里走到横跨泰晤士河的哈默史密斯桥。你朝南侧走去，那里的水最深，你把铅字扔进了河里。这不仅仅是一晚上的事，因为托马斯，你一次能带多少铅字？10到15磅？总共又有多少铅字？至少2600磅。所以，要摆脱2600磅的金属铅字，每次最多15磅，意味着你去了这座桥多少次？
You're a printer, not a mathematician. Thank you, Emery. 173. It took Thomas, a minimum of 173 trips, to throw away all of the Doves type. Each night you took the latest page of type that you'd finished printing with and wrapped it up in white paper
你是个印刷工，不是数学家。谢谢你，埃默里。173次。托马斯至少去了173次，才把所有的Doves铅字扔掉。每天晚上，你把刚刚印完的最新一页铅字拿出来，用白纸包好
or put it in a bag or filled your pockets with it or your favourite put it into a wooden toolbox with a sliding lid so you could sprinkle it gently off the bridge. You didn't want to make a splash. You didn't want anyone to notice what you were doing. You were scared of being caught. It would be humiliating. It would be a crime because this type was legally promised to Emery.
或者把它装进袋子里，或者塞满你的口袋，或者像你最喜欢的那样，把它放进一个带滑动盖子的木制工具箱里，这样你就可以把它轻轻地撒下桥。你不想溅起水花。你不想让任何人注意到你在做什么。你害怕被抓。那将是奇耻大辱。那将是一种犯罪，因为这些铅字在法律上是承诺给埃默里的。
So you would wait until nobody else was around on foot. You would hope for a passing bus or car so the noise would cover any splashes. And you would tip the type into the water. Night after night. Page after page. Sometimes, Thomas, you messed up Once a boat appeared from under the bridge And you nearly threw the type right into it
所以你会等到四周没有行人的时候。你会盼望有公交车或汽车经过，这样噪音就能掩盖任何水花声。然后你会把铅字倾倒进水里。夜复一夜。页复一页。有时候，托马斯，你搞砸了。有一次，一艘船从桥下出现，你差点把铅字直接扔进船里。
Another time, your bundles of type dropped onto a ledge by the feet of the bridge And you were tormented by these two packages Conspicuously wrapped in bright white paper Sitting there in full view What if they gave you away? Someone passing by in a boat might think Oh, what are these?
还有一次，你的一捆捆铅字掉落在了桥墩脚下的一个岩架上，你被这两包东西折磨着。它们显眼地用亮白纸包着，就那样大喇喇地摆在那里。要是它们把你供出来怎么办？路过船上的人可能会想，哦，这些是什么？
And open them up and find the famous dove's type And oh, then there would be the police and the newspapers and the courts and the shame. The shame. Twice you started hiring a boat to go to retrieve the packages, but you decided that would be even more conspicuous. People on the bridge or on the river or its banks might think, hey, why is that guy in a boat picking up those packages? Did he throw a type away?
然后打开它们，发现了著名的Doves铅字，哦，接着就会有警察、报纸、法庭和耻辱。耻辱。你有两次开始雇船去取回这些包裹，但你觉得那样会更引人注目。桥上、河面上或岸上的人可能会想，嘿，那个船上的人为什么在捡那些包裹？他是把铅字扔掉了吗？
Officer! You justified your disposal of doves as making a bequest to the river. But this all took a toll on you. Late summer changed to autumn, changed to winter, and night after night, you, a 76-year-old man, walked a mile round trip through the bitter cold with as much metal as you could carry, metal that you loved so much,
警察！你把处理Doves铅字的举动辩解为对河流的遗赠。但这一切对你来说都是一种煎熬。夏末变成秋天，秋天变成冬天，夜复一夜，你，一个76岁的老人，在严寒中顶着你能携带的尽可能多的金属，往返步行了一英里，那些你如此深爱的金属，
you must destroy it rather than let it live without you. For five months, you kept making your trips to the bridge, and by the end of January 1917, you had drowned all the dark. Meld down the steel, grind down the stone. There's nothing left except dust and rust and bone. After closing the Doves press, Thomas destroyed all of the records. He said he wanted no history of petty details, only the books themselves.
你宁愿毁了它，也不愿让它没有你而存在。五个月里，你不断地去桥上，到1917年1月底，你已经淹死了所有的黑暗。熔化钢铁，磨碎石头。除了尘土、铁锈和白骨，什么也没有剩下。关闭Doves印刷所后，托马斯销毁了所有的记录。他说他不需要琐碎细节的历史，只要书本身。
I want the history of petty details, Thomas, and if you hadn't been such a petty details aficionado, So if you hadn't thrown a whole tight face into the river, I wouldn't be talking about you now. I remember you not because of the art and thoughts you added to the world, but the thing you took away. Is that really what you wanted? Is that the impression you wanted to leave? Thomas, you were feeling your age and the fragility of your health. So you sold everything you could sell. You needed to prepare for the future. Your wife Annie had lost so much of her money on the Doves Press.
我想要琐碎细节的历史，托马斯，如果你不是这样一个琐碎细节的爱好者，如果你没有把整副铅字扔进河里，我现在就不会谈论你了。我记住你不是因为你给世界增添的艺术和思想，而是你带走的东西。这真的是你想要的吗？这就是你想留下的印象吗？托马斯，你感到了自己的年迈和健康的脆弱。所以你卖掉了所有能卖的东西。你需要为未来做准备。你的妻子安妮在Doves印刷所上失去了太多的钱。
you wanted something for her to live on after you died, and to deal with the legal costs of you having destroyed the dove's type. On the 7th of September 1922, Thomas died peacefully in his bed in the attic of the dove's bindery. And after that, four things happened. Well, uncountable things happened. Nearly a decade on, girl power is back. My girls have announced that they are reforming for a world tour.
你想为她留点生活费，供你在死后使用，还要应付你销毁Doves铅字所带来的法律诉讼费用。1922年9月7日，托马斯在Doves装订厂阁楼的床上平静地去世了。在那之后，发生了四件事。好吧，发生了数不清的事。将近十年后，辣妹组合回归了。我的女孩们宣布她们将重组进行世界巡演。
Okay, we did the Olympics. Now they're back, back, back. We're going to be performing all of our hits. but we're going to focus on four things. One, the dove's type was, of course, supposed to become Emery's upon Thomas's death, so a few days after, not technically wrong, Emery, but really too soon. You asked Annie to hand it over, and of course she couldn't, because she didn't have it, so you started legal proceedings.
好吧，我们办了奥运会。现在她们又回来了，回来了，回来了。我们将表演我们所有的热门歌曲，但我们将重点关注四件事。第一，Doves铅字当然应该在托马斯死后归埃默里所有，所以几天后——从技术上讲没错，埃默里，但真的太早了——你要求安妮把它交出来，当然她做不到，因为她没有，所以你提起了法律诉讼。
However, Annie and Emery didn't fight it out for anywhere near as long as Thomas had. They settled quite quickly out of court. But that doesn't bring back the doves. or patch up the emotional damage for either of them. The second thing that happened, Thomas had kept very detailed journals for his last four decades, and on the fourth anniversary of his death, Annie published them. And there was no mention of Emery.
然而，安妮和埃默里并没有像托马斯那样争斗那么久。他们在庭外很快就和解了。但这并不能把Doves带回来，也不能修复他们任何一方的情感创伤。发生的第二件事是，托马斯在他最后的四十年里记下了非常详细的日记，在他逝世四周年的那天，安妮出版了这些日记。并且完全没有提到埃默里。
Plenty of detail about which lines of poetry had been printed in which ink. But no, Emery, nothing from all those years where you two hung out together at the socialist meetings and the printing scene parties, nothing from all those family holidays in the neighbouring cottages, nothing from all your good years or all the bad. Emery had been edited out of Thomas's life. Yes, they made it look like you hadn't existed,
有大量关于哪一行诗是用什么墨水印刷的细节。但没有，埃默里，没有你们俩在社会主义会议和印刷界派对上鬼混的那些年的任何事情，没有邻近小屋里所有家庭假期的任何事情，没有你们所有好时光或坏时光的任何事情。埃默里被从托马斯的生活中编辑掉了。是的，他们让你看起来好像不存在过，
but their final years were all about you, so they clearly didn't forget you. A hole where a memory used to be is still a memory-shaped hole. You take the type away and you've still got the words it made. You take the words away, and you've still got the impression they made. The third thing that happened, when Annie died four years after Thomas, her and Thomas's ashes were placed in urns in a wall at the end of their garden, backing onto the River Thames.
但他们最后的岁月都是关于你的，所以他们显然没有忘记你。一个曾经存放记忆的地方，现在依然是一个记忆形状的洞。你拿走了铅字，但你仍然拥有它创造的词语。你拿走了词语，但你仍然拥有它们留下的印象。发生的第三件事是，在托马斯死后四年安妮去世时，她和托马斯的骨灰被放在花园尽头一堵墙的骨灰瓮里，那堵墙背靠着泰晤士河。
Two years later, the river overflowed and their ashes were gulped up by the water. Thomas and Annie were reunited with the doves type that had consumed so much of the last third of their lives. Everything must end. the memories we made perhaps the real friends were the ones we threw away The fourth thing that happened Emory, you tried to resurrect the dove's type
两年后，河水泛滥，他们的骨灰被水吞没了。托马斯和安妮与那些吞噬了他们最后三分之一生命的Doves铅字重新团聚了。一切都必须结束。我们创造的记忆，也许真正的朋友就是我们扔掉的那些。发生的第四件事，埃默里，你试图复活Doves铅字
You hired Edward Prince who had cut the original doves to remake it But it was too late. By then Edward Prince was in his late 70s His eyes and hands could no longer do such small, Fiddly work to such exact specifications Or maybe the real problem was you can't recreate a memory. So Dove's Type remained drowned and dead for close to a century until, in 2010, type designer Robert Green decided to try remaking it.
你雇用了曾刻制最初的Doves字体的爱德华·普林斯来重新制作它。但为时已晚。当时爱德华·普林斯已经七十多岁了。他的眼睛和手再也无法按照如此精确的规格进行如此细小、繁琐的工作了。或者真正的问题是你无法重现记忆。因此，Doves铅字被淹没并消亡了近一个世纪，直到2010年，字形设计师罗伯特·格林决定尝试重新制作它。
I'm a freelance graphic designer. I was in between jobs, and I had nothing to do. I might as well just redraw this typeface. How hard can it be, you know? Famous last word. He researched and drew and redrew the letters, working off how they appeared on the pages printed by the Doves Press. But from those, he couldn't reconstruct the type exactly, because every time the metal meets the page,
我是一名自由职业平面设计师。我当时正处于工作间隙，无所事事。我不妨重新绘制这个字体。能有多难，你知道的。著名的临终遗言。他进行研究、绘制并重新绘制了字母，参考了它们在Doves印刷所印刷的页面上的外观。但从这些页面中，他无法准确地重建铅字，因为每次金属遇到页面，
the ink leaves a slightly different shape on the paper. It's like tracing around coastline. You've got the coastline of the land when the tide is in, and then the tide goes out slightly. After working on it for three years, Robert released a digital version of Doves type. But he wasn't all that such. satisfied with it.
墨水在纸上留下的形状略有不同。这就像沿着海岸线描摹。你有涨潮时的陆地海岸线，然后潮水稍微退去。经过三年的努力，罗伯特发布了Doves字体的数字版本。但他对此并不是十分满意。
It's only going to be an impression of an impression, your idealised version of something. Robert decided he needed to see the original Doves type for himself, and in 2014, he went looking for it in the River Tense. And beneath Hammersmith Bridge, at low tide, after only 20 minutes of searching for these tiny pieces of metal not much thicker than a matchstick, he found a low-smitter.
它只不过是一个印象的印象，是你对某事物的理想化版本。罗伯特决定他需要亲自去看原版的Doves铅字，2014年，他在泰晤士河中寻找它们。在退潮时的哈默史密斯桥下，只花了20分钟寻找这些比火柴棍粗不了多少的微小金属碎片，他就找到了一个低矮的smitter。
lowercase V, and then an I and an E. When you're handling something that nobody's touched for, in this case, it was nearly 100 years, it's like for a second time collapses. It did feel like I just literally reached out and caught it as he dropped it. And that's a very strange feeling. Robert returned to the spot with a team of divers, and altogether they found 151 pieces of dove's type, just a fraction of a full set, but there was enough for Robert to be able to see far more detail of the original letters and hone his designs. He added more characters like the at sign they hadn't needed yet in 1900,
小写的v，然后是一个i和一个e。当你经手那些在——本案中是——将近100年里没有人碰过的东西时，感觉就像时间在第二次崩塌。这确实感觉就像我真的伸手把它抓住了，就在它掉落的时候。这是一种非常奇怪的感觉。罗伯特带着一队潜水员重返那个地点，他们一共找到了151片Doves铅字，这只是一整套字的一小部分，但已经足够让罗伯特看到原版字母的更多细节并磨练他的设计。他添加了更多的字符，比如在1900年还不需要的at符号，
and he made an alternative version of the lowercase why, because Emery had always found the design of the original one too aggressive. and Robert has released his updated version of doves for public use and anyone who buys it can use it for whatever they want. And this is exactly why Cobbden Sanderson threw it in the river. He didn't want it used for advertising and things that he didn't approve of. He only wanted the finest literature through his lens of what the finest literature and poetry and philosophy was.
他还制作了小写y的替代版本，因为埃默里一直觉得原版的设计太具有攻击性了。罗伯特发布了他更新版本的Doves供公众使用，任何购买它的人都可以将其用于他们想要的任何用途。这正是科布登-桑德森把它扔进河里的原因。他不想让它被用于广告和他不认可的事情。他只想通过他对什么是最好的文学、诗歌和哲学的视角来展现最好的文学。
You know, he only ever wanted it used for that. nothing else. And of course you let it out into the world and people are going to use it for letters to their bank manager. But of course you put something out into the world, it's not yours anymore. There's nothing you can do about it. So sorry Thomas. We can now print what we want. Keep calm and carry on even though it's the wrong thought. Passive aggressive signs, posters of Live laugh, love, t-shirts for my stag weekend are eternal life for dubs. All those tiny monuments, two letters disappear. Impressions of your lives.
你知道，他只希望它被用于那个目的。别无其他。当然，你把它放到了世界上，人们会用它来写信给他们的银行经理。但当然，你把一些东西释放到世界上，它就不再属于你了。你对此无可奈何。所以很抱歉，托马斯。我们现在可以打印我们想要的了。保持冷静并继续前行，即使这是一个错误的念头。被动攻击的标语、Live laugh love的海报、我单身派对的T恤，这些都是Doves的永生。所有那些微小的纪念碑，两个字母消失了。你们生活的印记。
In perfect souvenir. Souvenirs was written, performed and produced by Helen Zaltzman and Martin Austwick, with Adrian Lebel on violin. It was a falling tree production for BBC Radio 4. After the break, Helen and I talk about the inspiration behind her live shows. So we're back with Helen Zaltzman. And I want to talk to you about this radio piece that's adapted from a live show of The Illusionist. And I want you to tell me about the creation of the live show, how you tell stories with music and sound that involve the audience.
完美的纪念品。《纪念品》由海伦·扎尔茨曼和马丁·奥斯特维克编写、表演和制作，阿德里安·勒贝尔小提琴演奏。这是BBC广播四台的一部落树制作。休息过后，我和海伦将讨论她现场表演背后的灵感。所以我们回来了，和海伦·扎尔茨曼在一起。我想和你谈谈这个广播节目，它是根据《幻术师》的现场表演改编的。我想请你告诉我现场表演的创作过程，你如何用涉及观众的音乐和声音来讲故事。
And how do you think of it differently than when you're creating radio? I suppose because it's very different communicating with a video. bunch of people in a room versus via the internet over, it could be a long time period between me making something, them listening to it, whereas stage is very immediate, but also you can get away with more, like you don't have to have as many footnotes I feel in a stage production, although I did take care over the factual correctness of this, because I hate to be corrected. And someone did come to see the show a couple of years ago who works with Robert Green that found the typeface, and he said that was very accurate.
你认为这和创作广播节目有什么不同？我想是因为与视频沟通非常不同。房间里的一群人与通过互联网，我制作某些东西和他们听到之间可能会有一段很长的时间，而舞台是非常直接的，但你也可以逃避更多，比如我觉得在舞台制作中你不必有那么多的脚注，尽管我对这个节目的真实性很小心，因为我讨厌被纠正。几年前确实有人来看演出，他在寻找字体的罗伯特·格林手下工作，他说这非常准确。
Nice. And I felt proud. Yeah. But usually a stage show, A, starts with a musical idea in my head, and B, is only written within 36 hours of the first performance. Oh, my goodness. Yeah, it's horrible. It's really horrible, Roman. How do I fix myself?
太好了。我感到很自豪。是的。但通常舞台演出，A，始于我脑海中的一个音乐构思，B，只有在首演前36小时内才写好。噢，天哪。是的，这太可怕了。这真的很可怕，罗曼。我该怎么拯救自己？
It's so bad. And then my husband, Martin, who plays the music, is like, I hate you so much. You always do this. And yet I know that he can pull it out the bag because it always happens. And why was this the right story to tell in the live context? I can't remember. I had pitched to an audio festival, resonate in Richmond, Virginia, that I wanted to do a stage performance where audience members played characters but using only a sound effect.
太糟糕了。然后我的丈夫马丁，也就是弹奏音乐的那个人，会说，我太讨厌你了。你总是这样。然而我知道他能化险为夷，因为事情总是这样。为什么这是在现场语境中讲述的正确故事？我不记得了。我曾向弗吉尼亚州里士满的音频节共鸣（resonate）提议，我想要做一个现场表演，让观众扮演角色，但仅使用音效。
And I had read about this story around the same time in just as obscure a mailout. But I don't know why I put the two together. But the more I learned about it, the more fascinating I found it, not really because of the type, but because of the... The friendship breakdown, they really were very, very important friends to each other for more than a decade. And then it was quite a short period during which everything fell apart, like within two years. And then this immense fallout and the fact that you could hatch a revenge plan that took so many years to execute, I don't have the patience for that. My revenge plan would have to be within 36 hours.
我大约在同一时间在一份同样晦涩的邮件里读到了这个故事。但我不知道我为什么要把它俩结合起来。但我了解得越多，就越觉得它引人入胜，其实不是因为铅字，而是因为……友谊的破裂，他们彼此之间确实是非常非常重要的朋友，长达十多年。然后是在极短的一段时间内，一切都崩溃了，比如在两年内。然后是这种巨大的影响，以及你可以策划一个需要耗费多年才能执行的复仇计划的事实，我可没有那份耐心。我的复仇计划必须在36小时内完成。
36 hours. All creation and destruction has to happen within 36 hours. Right. I think that's enough time. I mean, one of the things that strikes me when you're thinking about creating musical accompaniment to a piece is the tantalizing aspect of having these two different characters who can be personified in music, kind of like Peter and the Wolf, you know. That was what I was thinking. I had pitched Peter and the Wolf, but it's about Edwardian type design. But when I say it starts with a musical idea, it's literally me in the shower walking around thinking, oh, suddenly a little four-line chorus has popped into my head.
36小时。所有的创造和毁灭都必须在36小时内完成。对。我认为这有足够的时间。我是说，当你考虑为一个作品创作音乐伴奏时，打动我的一点是拥有这两个可以用音乐具象化的不同角色的迷人之处，有点像《彼得与狼》，你知道的。我当时就是这么想的。我曾提议过《彼得与狼》，但它是关于爱德华七世时代的字体设计的。但当我说是从一个音乐构思开始时，字面意思就是我在淋浴时走来走去，想着，哦，突然一个四句的小副歌蹦进了我的脑海。
And then if I tweak the words, that's where the emotional progression of the piece starts to form. Because I'm like, okay, so it starts here. And then it gets sadder, and then it gets angry, and then it gets very weird. Yeah, yeah. And that's all just tweaking a very silly little refrain. Yeah.
然后如果我调整歌词，作品的情感发展就在那里开始成形。因为我想，好吧，所以它从这里开始。然后它变得更悲伤，然后它变得愤怒，然后它变得非常诡异。是的，是的。这一切都只是在调整一个非常愚蠢的小副歌。是的。
You know, one of the things that struck me most when I heard it is when you bring in interview tape, which happens very late in the piece, which normally for a radio piece, it happens very early to establish that this. Yeah, but that's that's true. There's certain fact pattern of the story itself necessitates that maybe the interview tape happens later. But, you know, normally you would interview some historian and their voice would be. be up top and they would be helping you tell it or something like this. Like it would be unusual for like 75% of the piece to be your voice and music and then somebody comes in, you know, and, um, and it's really striking itself as almost a piece of music to have the voice come in to me. Like I was, I was like into it when it found this new gear kind of. Oh, cool. It is, I suppose, now you explained it to me. A really strange thing to do and I wonder why I did it. But I think partly because documentaries have been made about this before. Yeah. With the type designer Robert Green and doing it
你知道，当我听到它时最打动我的一点是，当你引入采访录音时，这在作品中发生得很晚，通常对于广播作品来说，它发生得很早以确立这一点。是的，但那是真的。故事本身的某些事实模式使得采访录音可能在晚些时候发生。但是，你知道的，通常你会采访某个历史学家，他们的声音会出现在最上面，他们会帮你讲述或者诸如此类。就像作品的75%是你的声音和音乐，然后某个人进来了，你知道的，这很不寻常，并且，嗯，声音的引入本身真的就像是一首音乐一样惊艳。就像我一样，当它找到这个新档位时，我有点被吸引进去了。哦，酷。这确实，现在你向我解释了。这是一件非常奇怪的事情，我想知道我为什么这么做。但我想部分是因为以前关于这个拍过纪录片。是的。与字形设计师罗伯特·格林合作，
in that way where it is coming at it from the history of the type. And also, these guys are remembered for two things, one of which is being friends with William Morris and the other is this typeface going in the river. But they're not really remembered for other things that they did. And for the emotions that I found so compelling. Yeah, yeah. So I think for me, that was the root rather than just this happened then, and these were the people that they were running around with and blah, blah, blah. Yeah, yeah.
以这种方式从字体的历史切入。而且，这些人被记住是因为两件事，其中一件是与威廉·莫里斯是朋友，另一件是这个字体落入河中。但他们并没有真正因为他们做过的事情而被记住。以及我发现如此引人注目的情感。是的，是的。所以我想对我来说，那是根源，而不仅仅是这发生在先，然后这些是他们与之交往的人，巴拉巴拉。是的，是的。
Not that those things aren't important, but someone else had already done it. Right, right. It's a different level of investigation to talk about their emotions in this process. But then we only have these sources that have survived. So we have a lot of letters and diary entries from Thomas Copton Sanderson. we have some letters from Emory, but Thomas has had typically more control of the narrative because he was just much more prolific in expressing himself. And so for a lot of decades, people thought Emory was the jerk because he hadn't complained as much.
倒不是说那些事情不重要，而是别人已经做过了。对的，对的。探讨他们在这一过程中的情感，是不同层级的调查。但接着我们只有这些幸存下来的资料。所以我们有托马斯·科普顿·桑德森的大量信件和日记条目。我们有一些埃默里的信件，但托马斯通常对叙事有更多的主导权，因为他在表达自己方面要多产得多。因此，在几十年里，人们觉得埃默里是个混蛋，因为他抱怨得没那么多。
Got it, got it. There's just a very weird little incidental detail. Yeah, please. And something that I found very funny that I would like to investigate further is this is not the only typeface disposed of in the River Thames. There have been several. And I think there has got to be a better way of disposed. of two plus tons of metal. It's lead.
明白了，明白了。有一个非常诡异的小细节。好的，请说。我发现了一件非常有趣、想进一步调查的事，那就是这并不是唯一被扔进泰晤士河的铅字字体。有好几副呢。而且我想，处理两吨多的金属肯定有更好的办法。那是铅。
It seems like that's not where it should go. Is there a short story of other typefaces that ended up in the Thames that you know of? There was a contemporary of Copton Sonson and Walker called Charles Ricketts, who was an illustrator, and he had a printing press called the Vail Press from 1896 to 1904, whereupon a fire destroyed all their woodcuts, and he and his business colleagues decided to shut it down. and threw the type in the river. So I don't know if that's where Thomas got the idea from and thought, well, this would be a nice benediction to the River Thames,
看起来那不应该是它去的地方。你知道有哪些其他字体的短篇故事最终也落入泰晤士河了吗？科普顿·桑森和沃克有一位同时代的人叫查尔斯·里基茨，他是一位插画家，他在1896年至1904年间经营一家名为“谷地出版社”的印刷厂，随后一场火灾烧毁了他所有的木刻版画，他和商业伙伴决定将其关停，并将铅字扔进了河里。所以我不知道托马斯是不是从那里得到的灵感，心想，好吧，这将是对泰晤士河的一个美好祝福，
whether he thought, what am I going to do, leave it on the curb? I can't do that. It's a good point. I mean, like, throwing things in river is a long history of the way in which you dispose things. You know what I mean? That's not unusual. It's just, I think it's unusual. It feels unusual when it comes to typefaces, I think.
还是他在想，我该怎么办，把它留在马路牙子上吗？我不能那样做。这倒是个好问题。我的意思是，把东西扔进河里有着处理废弃物悠久的历史。你知道我的意思吗？这并不罕见。只是，我认为这很不寻常。我想，当涉及到铅字时，感觉就很不寻常。
Yes, because it is such a huge thing. so much effort. This is, it's so heavy. Yeah. It's hard to really understand because the pieces of type are tiny. They're like a matchstick thick and less long, but each of those is two grams. Sorry, I don't know what that is in old money. And then there's hundreds of thousands of those, which really adds up. Real effort. But then again, like, where else could you put it? If you really were trying to get rid of it, you know, like it's not like the garbage man comes along, takes it. Yeah, what do you do with two tons of lead? It's just a question. that in the 21st century, we still struggle to answer.
是的，因为这是一件如此巨大的事。付出了这么多的努力。这是，它太沉了。是的。很难真正去理解，因为那些铅字很小。它们像火柴棍那么粗，还要短一些，但每一个都有两克。抱歉，我不知道用老式货币怎么算。然后有几十万个这样的铅字，加起来确实很多。真够费劲的。不过话又说回来，还能把它放到哪儿去呢？如果你真的想摆脱它，你知道的，不像垃圾工会过来把它收走。是的，你怎么处理两吨铅？这是一个我们在21世纪仍然难以回答的问题。
That's true. Can you melt it down and do something else with it? Do Etsy stuff? You probably do a lot of Etsy stuff. Yeah. Well, Helen Salsman, it's some fun to talk to you. Thank you very much for having me. Our interview with Helen Saltzman was produced by Jacob Medina Gleason.
确实如此。你能把它熔化再做点别的吗？做点Etsy风格的手工艺品？你大概能做很多Etsy风格的东西吧。好的，海伦·萨尔斯曼，和你聊天非常开心。非常感谢邀请我。我们对海伦·萨尔斯曼的采访由雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森制作。
Mixed by Martine Gansalice, music by Swan Real. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director, Delaney Holstead. is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Jonathan, Vivian Leigh, Loshamaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building, in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as
由玛蒂娜·甘萨利斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。凯西·图也是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德兰妮·霍尔斯特德是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·乔纳森、薇薇安·李、洛沙·马多恩、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、塔林和雷恩·斯特德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。“99%隐形”的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创建。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北面六个街区外的潘多拉大楼，坐落在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及
our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，还有99PI每一期往期节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。